es demasiado común en esa familia.
El hecho mismo de que sean raros
atrae nuestra atención,
y nos lleva a nuevas formas de pensar.
Muchos de Uds. podrían decir, correctamente,
'Kevin, es genial,
pero no estás hablando de las alas de un pájaro.
No estás hablando de las lunas
flotando alrededor de Júpiter.
Es una persona.
Esta excepción, este caso aparte,
puede ayudar con el avance de la ciencia,
pero es una persona.
Y todo lo que puedo responder
es que lo sé demasiado bien.
Converso con estos pacientes con enfermedades raras y letales.
Escribo sobre estas conversaciones.
Estás conversaciones son muy tensas
Están cargadas de frases horribles
como 'tengo malas noticias' o 'no hay nada que más que podamos hacer'
A veces estas conversaciones se transforman en una sola palabra:
'terminal'.
El silencio también puede ser muy incómodo.
Los vacíos en medicina
pueden ser tan importantes como
las palabras que usamos en estas conversaciones.
¿Qué es lo desconocido?
¿Qué experimentos se están realizando?
Hagan este pequeño ejercicio conmigo:
En la pantalla está esta frase: 'ningún cuando'
Noten dónde está el espacio.
Si se cambia tan solo una letra
'ningún cuando'
se transforma en 'ahora aqui'.
El significado opuesto.
Solo al mover una letra.
Nunca olvidaré la noche que entré al cuarto de un paciente.
Había estado operando todo el día,
pero aún quería ir a verlo.
Un niño al que había diagnosticado con cáncer de huesos unos días antes.
Él y su mamá se habían reunido con doctores de quimioterapia
ese mismo día
y había sido ingresado para comenzar el tratamiento.
Era casi medianoche cuando llegué a su cuarto
Él dormía, pero encontré a su madre
leyendo con una linterna
junto a su cama.
Salió al pasillo a hablarme unos minutos
Lo que estaba leyendo era el protocolo de quimioterapia
entregado por los doctores ese día.
Lo había memorizado.
Me dijo: 'Dr. Jones, me dijo que no siempre
se vence este tipo de cáncer,
pero he estudiado el protocolo y creo poder hacerlo.
Creo que puedo seguir estos difíciles tratamientos
Renunciaré a mí trabajo. me mudaré con mis padres.
Mantendré a mi bebé seguro'
No le dije.
No me detuve a corregir su pensamiento.
Ella creía en un protocolo
que, incluso si lo siguiera,
no necesariamente salvaría a su hijo.
No le dije.
No rellené el vacío.
Pero un año y medio después
el niño aun así murió de cáncer.
¿Debería haberle dicho?
Muchos de Uds. preguntarán '¿y?'
No tengo sarcoma.
Nadie en mi familia tiene sarcoma.
Y está todo bien, pero probablemente no importa en mi vida'
Y probablemente están en lo correcto.
El sarcoma quizás no los afecte mucho en su vida.
Pero dónde están los vacíos en la medicina
si importa en tu vida.
No les conté un pequeño y sucio secreto.
Les dije que en la medicina, testeamos predicciones en poblaciones,
pero no les dije,
y la medicina nunca les dice
que cada vez que un individuo
se enfrenta a la medicina
incluso si el individuo es parte de la población general,
ni el individuo ni el doctor sabe
dónde en la población se encontrará el individuo.
Así, cada encuentro con la medicina
es un experimento.
Serán sujetos de un experimento.
Y el resultado será o algo bueno o malo para ti.
Mientras la medicina funcione bien,
estamos bien con el servicio rápido,
bravuconería, con conversaciones confianzudas.
Pero cuando las cosas no funcionan tan bien,
a veces queremos algo diferente.
Un colega extirpó un tumor de la extremidad de un paciente.
Estaba preocupado por este tumor.
En nuestras conferencias médicas, habló de esta preocupación
que este tipo de tumor tenía un alto riesgo
de volver en la misma extremidad.
Pero las conversaciones con el paciente
eran exactamente lo que un paciente quería:
llenas de confianza.
El dijo 'lo extirpé todo y estás muy bien'
Ella y su esposo están muy felices.
Salieron, celebraron, cena formal, abrieron una botella de champán.
El único problema fue que, unas semanas después,
comenzó a notar otro nódulo en la misma área.
No extirpó todo y ella no estaba bien
pero lo que pasó en esta instancia me fascina.
Mi colega se acercó y me dijo
Kevin, ¿podrías cuidar a este paciente por mí?
Le pregunté: '¿Por qué?
Sabes lo que hay que hacer igual que yo.
No has hecho nada malo.'
Dijo 'Por favor, solo trátala por mí'.
Estaba avergonzado,
no por lo que había hecho,
sino por la conversación que había tenido
el exceso de confianza.
Así que realicé una cirugía mucho más invasiva.
Y tuve una conversación muy diferente con la paciente después.
Dije 'es muy probable que lo haya sacado todo
y es muy probable que estés bien
pero este es el experimento que estamos realizando.
Esto es lo que buscarás. Esto es lo que buscaré.
y trabajaremos juntos para ver
si esta cirugía funcionará para eliminar tu cáncer'.
Puedo asegurarles, ella y su marido
no abrieron otra botella de champán después de hablarme.
Pero ahora era una científica
no solo la sujeto en su experimento.
Así que los aliento
a buscar humildad y curiosidad
en sus doctores.
Casi 20 mil millones cada año,
una persona entra a una consulta
y se transforma en un paciente.
Uds. o alguien que aman serán ese paciente pronto.
¿Cómo hablarán con sus doctores?
¿Qué les dirán?
¿Qué les dirán ellos a Uds.?
No pueden decirte lo que no saben,
pero pueden decirte cuando no saben
tan sólo si preguntan.
Así que por favor, únanse a la conversación.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)